hello by now you've heard that our  Volkswagen diesel cars were designed to  cheat on emissions tests but we don't  understand why no one's talking about  all our other wonderfully deceitful  features for example the on-board  computer can hack into police radar guns  if you want to illegally use the carpool  lane our engines will reroute the  exhaust to create a passenger made of  smog automatic fake handicapped parking  permits come standard stalking your ex  is easier than ever with a new VW  invisibility cloak technology and at  night while you sleep our diesel  vehicles will go out and mug people and  bring you the wallets  Volkswagon it feels so good to be so bad  [Applause]